hello
hey um so
yeah i kind of wanted to give a
different talk about some other stuff
but that wasn't ready and so this is
kind of a
makeup talk uh it's been some
years since node came out and it's kind
of stabilized
and it's a thing and it's kind of going
into this
direction so i thought i would kind of
look back on it and and
tell you what i think about uh node
so sorry i'm a little nervous
excuse my wavering voice uh
so right some background i created node
and managed it through its initial
development for a couple of years
and my goal as you may know that
was really around io and
uh evented doing doing event driven i o
in javascript
and i think that focus was really
important
in 2009 for getting server-side
javascript off the ground uh because
as we know now javascript is single
threaded and
like oh i'm sorry and uh
sorry i lost my train of thought yeah
javascript is single threaded blah blah
blah
uh that allowed uh
node to succeed um so
right when i left in 2012 i feel like
node was more or less
doing well in the i o department
like we had protocols supported like
http
and https and after
a massive effort we ported node to
windows using
like very nice system calls called iocp
and we were running on linux and mac and
it had a relatively small core i mean it
kind of
got out of hand a little bit but it was
okay
and has somewhat stable api and npm was
out
and there were people adding modules
i was like this project is done now um
so wrong uh
so right i mean obviously this is this
is a
a tremendous effort to to keep node
running on everybody's machines as it
does today and keep it updated with
javascript and uh you know fix
uh the issues with it and many people
have
uh been involved in this effort many of
them
are here um
and i'm sorry i'm probably leaving out
many important people
so i personally was kind of done with
node
and went on to do other things
and it's only really in the last six
months that i've started using it
heavily again largely because
go came out and i was interested in
servers and doing
fast servers and go is a better language
for doing fast servers
and so there was no need for me to to be
using node
um but i think actually node is quite
nice i javascript is really quite nice
in particular uh dynamic languages are
very nice
uh and
they're nice for certain things i should
say i think if you're building a server
and you want to really control every
aspect of it absolutely you want it to
be statically typed
but in scientific computing for example
uh there's a lot of kind of one-off
calculations where you're just kind of
you know typing into a jupiter notebook
and you really don't want to hit a type
error at that point you're just trying
to plot something right
there is a time and place for dynamic
languages
prototyping things is another situation
like you want to move very fast
you don't want to worry about what the
abstractions are you just want to
be dynamic and javascript obviously
i mean maybe there's many people that
don't agree but
here they do it's is the best dynamic
language
so right using node is
uh kind of like nails on chalkboard to
me
at times just because um
i see the bugs that i introduced
that aren't really bugs at this point
they're just how it works but
they are bugs and there were design
mistakes
made that just cannot be corrected now
because there's so much software that
uses it um and it's it's uh
i don't know it offends my sensibilities
uh
it could have been much nicer so
uh one regret would be that i didn't
stick with promises
so promises were added very early and
i foolishly removed them not very long
after
with the idea that we should be minimal
and promises introduce an extra object
into every
callback and i can see my reasoning at
the time but
had that gone differently it might have
made
the ecosystem around building async
await
stuff uh happen faster
unclear it's an alternate history that
we'll never know
uh maybe it was a good thing that
promises were removed because it allowed
the ecosystem to kind of develop their
own tools and we found the right
abstraction
um but i have often thought that
i wish i had left that in that was a
rash decision
um did i say all of this
yeah another regret is security
because javascript is a very secure
sandbox unlike python right
and unfortunately in node we just bound
to everything and there's zero security
right you run a
node program you have access to all
sorts of system calls
and that was really a
missed opportunity to be able to make a
server-side runtime that could
potentially be secure in certain
situations obviously if you want to
you know give access to the disk then
people are going to be able to exploit
the disk but there are certain
situations where you want to run a
program
outside of the web browser but you don't
necessarily want it to be able to write
to the desk or
access the network right for example a
linter it would be nice for me to be
able to download the massive code base
that eslint is
and run that without having to worry
about it taking over my computer which
it could
so uh yeah probably the biggest regret
is the build system such a pain
uh build systems are very very difficult
and very very important to building
projects
node uses this thing called jip do you
guys know jip
some of you if you're writing a module
that does
that links to a c library you use this
thing called
jip to compile that c library uh
and link it into node right um
jip is this thing that chrome used to
use and
but chrome uh like abandoned jip for
this other tool called gn
several years later we couldn't have
predicted that
but that's what happened and now it's
been many years since that happened
and node is the sole user of jip it's a
very funky
interface it's like a json file but it's
in python
it's it's very terrible node has several
wrappers around this one of them is
called node jip
it just layers upon layers of
unnecessary complexity v8 doesn't build
with jip anymore it has a [ __ ] wrapper to
support
node but i mean there's just so much
unnecessary complexity there
and yeah frankly i'm i think this is one
of the biggest failures
of the node technical leadership uh
it should be dealt with uh so
i think yeah i i
i'm not sure which direction would be
the right way to go at this point
um it's a difficult problem there's a
lot of
software to support but uh
i do think that i kind of made a
uh not kind of rash decision
in thinking that everybody should
compile their extension modules
we could have gone with a foreign
function interface which doesn't require
any compiling necessarily
although you still have to have your
dependencies there
but i think this could have been a much
more natural and
easy interface for people who want to
link to system libraries
and many people suggested this to me
namely brian cantrell but i totally
ignored them
um and yeah
libyuv uh moved to auto tools which is
just unacceptable and regrettable
you know who you are
um i didn't do that that's a regret
for somebody else
so uh right another thing package json
package json is like the lifeblood of of
javascript at this point
um but you know at some point it wasn't
and isaac of npm fame
uh more or less defined it although
there might have been some sort of uh
specification
and i largely sanctioned it and made it
popular by allowing
require in node semantics to look into
package json and look through files
so this makes package json
basically necessary for for programs for
for node programs where it was not
before
um and then ultimately i included npm
into
node which made npm the standard uh
uh node distribution service
and um yeah
so
i have this problem with is a little
abstract but in your in your
javascript program right if you require
some module
that doesn't completely specify what
that module is
it also needs to be defined in your
package.json
that's part of the module resolution
algorithm
like which version it is and whatnot um
in order to install it and you also have
this
node modules folder which does the
module resolution
so you know kind of linking to a package
requires a lot of systems here
a lot of components that is not what's
that
icloud all right um
yeah so uh
yeah i mean package.json i think the my
the problem i have with it
is that it gives this rise to a concept
of a module
as this directory of files where that
wasn't really a concept before like we
just had javascript files like on the
web you just have
javascript files and you can you know
script tag include them all over the
place there's no like
thing there's no like module package as
there is in npm it's not a strictly
necessary abstraction
um and package.json just has like all
this unnecessary noise in it
like license repository it's like why am
i filling this out like i feel like a
bookkeeper or something like this is
just
unnecessary stuff to do when all i'm
trying to do
is link to a library um
yeah i'll get to relative urls and of
course
node modules get very big because it
kind of has this vendoring by default
semantics where
modules are installed installed locally
into your into your project folder and
so
you tend to have if you have multiple
projects you have multiple node modules
folders and
it gets big this was my idea i
regret it uh
this this the whole algorithm for
resolving module names is just
wildly complex it's it's
kind of been added to over time in ways
that
are yeah regrettable
i feel like you know the vendored by
default
uh idea behind node modules which
which is what i was going for there was
kind of had good intentions right that
we know exactly what we're linking to it
was supposed to be explicit
but in practice like a node path type
thing a python path type thing would
have
would have worked right you can do
vendoring that way too you just set an
environmental variable
it just it deviates greatly from how
browsers do stuff
and it's my fault and i'm very sorry and
unfortunately it's impossible to
in undo now
also this whole thing where you don't
include the extension in the in the
require module
why uh it's like needlessly
non-explicit you now have to like probe
the file system for different things did
you mean js did you mean
ts did you mean blah blah like no just
write the
extension in there um
so i'm
i'm glad that you guys agree with me
because there is still some debate about
this
this stuff um people like the
the extension list thing it's cleaner
like no
uh yeah said all that also
index.js i'm sorry okay i thought it was
cute there's index.html
i thought it would be cute for like you
know when you include a directory it
would look up the index
the index.js sorry
this was like needlessly introduced uh
what i've come to learn now that i'm
aging
is that like whenever you're designing a
program like
there's things that you think might be
cute to add in
you always regret those if they are if
they are unnecessary and simply
cute like don't do them uh
yeah so yeah my problems with node are
not so much around the i o and i
honestly i like node i like programming
in it i think it's it's
relatively nice it's it's unixy
but it's my problems are more to do with
the module system and how
it manages user code and i think this is
largely because when i was making node
like
it was very focused on getting this i o
stuff i was like nerding out hardcore
on like epoll and
kind of yeah i mean the the module
system was essentially an afterthought
that got added on as users needed this
stuff and it is reflected in the
in how node works now um so yeah with
that in mind
um i was you know writing up this talk
and
it seemed very negative and i thought
like it was kind of
shitty to like come up in front of
people and like complain about stuff
without like giving you know it feel
like you should offer some sort of
solution
or like at least a prototype of how
things might be differently
or how like node might be differently if
you designed it today
and i'll say is that like don't try out
this code it's
it's very very unusable at this moment
it does not do anything
and unless you are well versed in ldb
lldb
uh you should not try bother try
building it
but that said um you might want to check
out
deno is a a secure typescript runtime
on v8 working on the tagline not
not so sure about that uh so
this is a new piece of software uh it's
one month old
but let me let me this is just kind of
me riffing on what
i think would be a nice server-side
javascript runtime these days
obviously evented i o is taken for
granted yes obviously we want to do that
we have to do that
what else is important so for one
security
it would be nice to utilize the fact
that javascript is a secure sandbox
by default a script should run without
any network or file system
write access and that users can then opt
into
various access so if you want to allow
it to access the network you do
allow net right and so this allows
people
in some situations where you have and i
think this is
more common that you might realize you
have some code that you just want to run
without giving it any sort of
uh without giving it much access to the
system that you're running on
and uh this allows you to do that via
uh the the fact that javascript is a is
a runtime we just don't
bind we don't allow the the uh
the system to reach into the operating
system we don't allow v8 to run reach
into the operating system
um yeah and uh i don't allow arbitrary
native functions to be bound into v8
all system calls are done through
message passing so there's a single
entry
point in and out of the vm unlike node
where it's just bound all over the place
and it's very difficult to keep track of
what is happening because there's no
single entry point
and this has caused a lot of
problems when trying to do things like
domains uh
and okay so there's there's this way of
like sending messages back and forth so
inside the v8 that you get there's only
really two native functions there's send
and receive
receive takes a callback send sends a
message um
and i think i've always thought for many
years that
like having this sort of message passing
thing would have been nice
in node um and so here's here's like a
vague uh
description of of what it is so you have
like the deno process
which is written in go at the moment
although i'm i'm debating
on whether that's the right choice um
and uh
you have v8 running there inside of it
and uh there's these send and receive uh
uh calls that are that are bound into v8
and
it can send and receive protobuf
messages right they're just buffer
arrays
uh array buffers and um
there's a dispatcher that kind of like
sends out messages
uh to various different modules so these
these modules can kind of
on both sides of the kind of privileged
and unprivileged boundary kind of sync
up and
and you know the ghost side can handle
the system calls and and
turn you know your your request for a
set timeout into
into a sleep or whatever and uh in v8
you have a similar module system
inside of v8 itself uh you have the
typescript compiler actually like built
into the
this whole executable i love typescript
it is
the best thing it is microsoft
uh i don't actually know the people who
did
this work at microsoft but man it is
very
pragmatic and well done and approachable
and i just love the fact that you can
you know start hacking in normal
javascript and just slowly kind of build
your project
up uh this was kind of one of the goals
of
uh dart
uh do you guys know dart
yeah total failure like jesus
uh i mean very good intentions and very
cool but
but obviously a failure at this point
and
typescript took a totally different
approach to the problem and
worked completely in javascript and
uh i think you know solved it in a way
that
uh is satisfying many people so if you
have not been using typescript like
please
check it out i want this thing to do
typescript because i like it
um yeah and so also deno i want to
simplify the module system so screw all
this stuff about
uh you know how node modules work and
that like
but by the way i can't be compatible
with node like otherwise like you just
end up building nodes so there's no
attempt at
compatibility with existing software um
this is mostly just a thought experiment
right but
i think it would be cute if you just
import
via where the source code came from as
you do in the web
right there's a source file there you
link to that source file
and now you've linked it into your
program if it's a relative include you
do a relative include
um obviously you should provide an
extension
and then you might be wondering well i
don't want this source code like
changing out from under me this seems
fishy
well it won't so the first time you do
this if you don't have
that url loaded then it downloads it
and it caches it somewhere and
then it never it never updates that
again when you run it again it's it's
still using the same code
however you can do a dash dash reload as
you do in the web browser when you
that's my control r uh hand signal
you know um so you can do dash dash
reload and it has a similar semantics
where it will then do like a hard reload
of all the cache files
um and yeah you can do vendoring and
stuff by giving it a different place
where it downloads these
these files i think this is viable
um typescript compiler built into it
blah blah i already said that
uh denno hooks into
yeah so i mean basically typescript
should should work out of the box and
obviously javascript should
still work out of the box but that's
trivial because uh
you know typescript is a superset of
javascript
and um yeah
at the moment its startup time is is
quite slow it's like at one second which
is completely unacceptable
however i i am working on uh using v8
snapshots to snapshot the entire
compiler
and i am plus other optimizations that
haven't been done i'm
fairly confident that it can be improved
greatly
and so deno also i i don't like
shipping all of these files i hate that
i think it should be a single executable
so it should be an executable that
doesn't
link to too many things right so you can
just download this executable and run it
um and yeah just generally take
advantage of the fact that we're in the
future now
and like things are great so for example
in the build process in node there's
this very complicated
setup of like kind of defining require
and we have all these files and we have
to build them into a bundle blah blah
we have to load them all into the v8 but
now we have
parcel which is really great by the way
so what i can do is i can write kind of
a normal node
program structure for the internal
systems of deno
and then i can run parcel on it compile
it into a single thing
use it and that will use you know notes
module resolution scheme and stuff but
now i have a single
bundled uh javascript file and i can
just dump that into v8 so that makes
like the whole process of building this
thing much simpler uh
yeah and uh great infrastructure exists
now in native code right part of node
was like
writing a web server like we spent a lot
of time on the http parser
like you know there's no need to do that
like that's all done at this point you
can
if this ends up being go then you just
link into goes
http routines which are which are super
good or
you know maybe i'll use roster c plus
plus in either situation there are
uh easy ways to link into
uh high-level code high-level native
code these days
and i think that that really eases
uh the the job of of this
thing um
yeah uh and some miscellaneous things
like
just die immediately when you have an
unhandled promise i mean
like who who has ever wanted to like oh
maybe
i'll add a a catch handler later like
and i don't want this to die immediately
no like
it should die as soon as it gets an
error
uh should support top level of weight i
haven't got it working yet but
it's not hard and uh yeah
be browser compatible like in node like
uh
you know i i remember thinking like
window is a really dumb
variable name for the global scope like
why call it window it's
it's not a window it should be called
global um
yeah i don't know i that was that was a
mistake because now we have this whole
like
incompatibility issue with the browser
so like
where deno will overlap with the browser
it should be
it should use the browser semantics the
browser variable names the browser
functions and whatnot so yeah check it
out
maybe i don't know it's a prototype it
was just
uh yeah i think i'm i'm
mildly happy with it so far
yeah if you have any comments or
questions i guess you can't ask them me
now
but please email me and yeah
uh i don't know first person to
implement an http server gets a star
um this is them out of my talk i don't i
still have
three minutes left so thanks thanks for
having me here